ah I'm tell you I feel sorry if I had to
retire you know why I have some many
customers I see Alex you never retired
yes they do what they have to retire you
know
my name is Ali Alex Carozza and I fix
accordion since 1960 in New York the
people comes from all over the world to
fix the choreo because they say that I'm
the best I don't know
this some time brakes you have to change
very difficult I'm the only one in New
York to fix accordion in this moment you
know see I fix the accordion and I do
the custom because I fix according
correctly only I have this one for this
in particular this is a very old forest
whoa at least this according 75 years
old how old are you hi if I tell you you
won't believe it
I'm 88 you believe it it's red Howard is
him if I tell you 93 you won't believe
it we working together 60 years since
1949 let yesterday
yeah it looks like a gesture you can
understand an instrument is like some
part of your life you care for the
instrument more than anything else I
love this more than anything else it's
not the morning sometime in life if
you're healthy and happy
money doesn't count this is what I
believe maybe I'm wrong but now you have
all my secret good
de nada okay